[Musique]
bienvenue dans auditions publiques sur
Public Sénat et LCP avec cette question
qu'on va poser dans à notre invité dans
quelques instants les Français
seront-ils bien soignés cet été question
très pertinente puisque vous le savez
depuis plusieurs années on constate une
saturation des services un épuisement
des personnels des fermetures de lit pas
toujours comprises ou justifiées les
grandes chaleurs qui commencent d'un
Range rien quel est le tableau c'est la
question qu'on va vous poser François
brode merci beaucoup d'être notre invité
ce soir vous êtes ministre de la Santé
vous avez été pendant plus de 30 ans 38
ans je crois sauf erreur
urgentiste et vous aviez dit lorsque
vous êtes arrivés au gouvernement il y a
presque un entou pile vous aviez dit je
suis
urgentiste le resterait et j'ai la
volonté de régler le plus rapidement
possible les problèmes qu'avez-vous
amélioré monsieur le ministre depuis un
an c'est la question qu'on va vous poser
on vous interrogera aussi sur votre
surface politique comme on dit votre
présence au le nom est contesté vous ne
donneriez pas assez de visibilité à vos
dossiers pourtant cruciaux comment
répondez-vous aux critiques on évoquera
aussi le droit l'euthanasie le Sénat
n'en veut pas vers quoi vous
orientez-vous la concertation n'a pas
permis semble-t-il de dégager un
consensus est-ce un échec quel sera
finalement la copie du gouvernement au
fait on ne parle plus du tout du covid a
juste titre le virus a disparu plus
besoin de rappel de vaccins vous ne
direz tout à l'heure ce qu'il faut en
penser Brigitte boucher tome tranny et
Vincent roux reviendront sur toutes ces
questions d'actualité Jim jarre AC du
Figaro évoquera avec vous le remaniement
est-ce que vous aimeriez rester à votre
poste merci en tout cas d'avoir accepté
aussi le principe du débat avec le
député elle est fille Damien Maudet qui
s'opposera la question comment
relocaliser la fabrication la
fabrication des médicaments c'est riches
comme programme première question
réponse bref si c'est possible vous êtes
depuis un an je le disais au
gouvernement qu'est-ce qui vous frappe
quand on est ministre qu'est-ce qu'il
vous frappe dans cette fonction dans le
fond vous qui venez de la société civile
l'importance de la charge la
responsabilité de prendre des décisions
en tant qu'urgentiste j'ai l'habitude
j'avais l'habitude de prendre des
décisions concernant impatient voire
plusieurs patients mais là chaque
décision
concerne l'ensemble des Français donc
c'est une charge qui est importante si
je vous demande
puis un an j'espère pour vous en avez
plusieurs mais une au moins oui j'en ai
plusieurs je pourrais vous parler de
tout ce qu'on a déjà fait ce que j'ai
porté sur la prévention mais puis sur
l'hôpital je pense qu'on en parlera tout
à l'heure mais peut-être rappeler
quelque chose dont on ne parle plus qui
est passé inaperçu et pour laquelle la
France et j'en suis je suis très fier a
eu insatisficie de l'OMS c'est la
gestion de la crise de mon K-pop
dariotte du singe
on a beaucoup parlé à la fin de l'année
dernière et je pense que la gestion a
été a été très bonne et l'OMS nous a
donné insatisfait site à la France pour
la façon de cette crise avait été gérée
et comme on ne parle pas des trains qui
arrivent à l'heure c'est vrai que c'est
un peu passé sous les radins mais à
culpa monsieur le ministre
mais à culpa
peut-être le
oui le non n'aboutissement de la
négociation conventionnelle avec les
médecins généralistes
la négociation
je pense que le l'objectif est
l'objectif est bon et j'ai depuis
discuter avec et je continue à discuter
avec les syndicats de médecins
l'objectif est bon mais peut-être que je
ne l'ai pas assez mis en avant donc ce
qui est le cas actuel
pas suffisamment et vos relations avec
les syndicats une note de 0 à 10 8 donc
plutôt satisfaite pas de problème
depuis longtemps de par mon passé
syndical et oui nous avons des échanges
qui sont qui sont très très fluides mais
effectivement j'ai pas réussi à
convaincre donc attends je m'attelle à
continuer à les convaincre l'objectif
est le même mais peut-être que le chemin
à prendre sera différent
la situation à l'hôpital public monsieur
le ministre n'a jamais été aussi grave
il s'effondre par panzanier c'est ce qui
crie
syndicale des praticiens
hospitaliers que dites-vous de cette
phrase est-ce que la situation de
l'hôpital public est difficile et
compliqué que ce n'est malheureusement
pas nouveau que gore de mes déplacements
sur le terrain j'étais encore à Vendôme
ce matin j'étais à Clermont-Ferrand
jeudi dernier ce n'est pas du tout le
message qui est porté par les
professionnels de terrain il considère
que la situation est dans la situation
la situation est difficile c'est plus
contrasté que cela il y a une
une refondation de notre système de
santé à laquelle participent l'hôpital
public c'est souhaité c'est volontaires
mais il faut savoir que les difficultés
de l'hôpital public sont essentiellement
liées à du manque de personnel manque de
personnel médical
je pense qu'il aurait fallu prendre les
décisions du numérique bien avant
heureusement que le gouvernement
précédent les a prises pour faire sauter
ce numerus et puis aussi de personnels
paramédicales avec cet enjeu majeur
d'attractivité de notre hospital public
sur lequel je travaille avec les
organisations syndicales donc dans le
fond vous dites en un an je ne pouvais
pas redresser à moi tout seul la
montagne de problèmes que qui qui pèse
sur l'hôpital public je l'ai dit je l'ai
dit dès que je suis arrivé la
temporalité de du système de santé c'est
pas une temporalité à un an ou à six
mois ou même à deux ans l'enjeu
principal et c'est ce que m'a confié la
première ministre et le président de la
République c'est cette refondation de
notre système de santé cette fondation
la prise par la base avec des conseils
nationaux de la refondation de la santé
au niveau des territoires en allant
chercher les complications les solutions
aussi à l'échelle de chaque territoire
et en fabriquant cette boîte à outils
pour refonder notre système notre
système qui était basé sur l'offre de
soins et que je travaille à refonder sur
la réponse aux besoins de santé de la
population ça fait un peu technique mais
c'est vraiment ça le cœur même de la
politique que je conduis mais alors
c'est pas forcément très technique c'est
très concret aussi les questions qui se
posent aujourd'hui dans le domaine de la
santé se sont Brigitte Boucher est entre
amis qui nous ont rejoints qui vont vous
poser un certain nombre de questions
crimes on va dire on va commencer par
parler d'un sujet que vous connaissez
bien comme praticien et comme ministre
la situation des urgences qu'on nous
annonce sous haute tension cet été
est-ce que tous les Français qui en ont
besoin pourront être pris en charge par
les urgences tous les Français qui en
ont besoin seront pris en charge dans
les situations
urgentes pour cela et bien il y a un
réflexe et je profite sur votre antenne
pour rappeler ce réflexe si vous
n'arrivez pas à joindre votre médecin
traitant s'il n'est pas disponible vous
faites le 15 vous appelez le SAMU en
fait qui évolue vers le service d'accès
aux soins qui est en train de
s'installer partout parce que la
solution va se présenter aux urgences
sans avoir appelé le 15 aujourd'hui il
vaut mieux éviter parce que si vous
présentez aux urgences et votre cas ne
relève pas du service des urgences ça
veut pas dire qu'il est pas que vous qui
n'est pas considéré comme urgent pour
vous mais une relève pas du service des
urgences bien vous allez attendre et
vous allez attendre beaucoup parce que
passeront devant vous des gens dont la
situation sera plus urgente alors que si
vous appelez le 15 vous allez avoir très
vite un médecin rappelons quand même ça
dans notre France c'est que où que vous
soyez quel que soit l'heure du jour et
de la nuit vous faites le 15 vous avez
en une à trois minutes médecin au
téléphone ce médecin va évaluer votre
situation s'il relève de la médecine
générale il va vous orienter près du
médecin on nous annonce quand même
beaucoup de fermeture de services
d'urgence cet été ce que vous avez un
chiffre à nous donner non parce qu'il
n'y a pas de fermeture de service
d'urgence il y en a pas il y a quelques
exceptions dans des réorganisations
territoriales mais il y a un accès
régulier aux urgences il y a des
fermetures de fait il y a des
réorganisations mais qui sont oui quand
vous avez trois services d'urgence dans
une ville que pendant cet été voire même
plus tard demain il se sont mis d'accord
pour concentrer sur deux services
simplement
mais c'est de la réorganisation comment
l'offre de soins sont réduites
donc on arrête d'avoir des décisions
verticales il faut qu'on laisse la
latence on laisse de la possibilité aux
gens sur le territoire de s'organiser si
dans une ville vous avez trois services
d'urgence et que les entre eux ils
considèrent que ce regrouper va leur
permettre de mieux prendre en charge des
patients urgent et en même temps avec de
la régulation médicale préalable pour
diminuer la fréquentation des urgences
laissons les faire mais il n'y a pas
j'entends partout parler de service
d'urgence qui ferme les services
d'urgence sont un accès régulier ça veut
dire que quand on arrive aux urgences on
est en contact soit avec le médecin du
Samu par téléphone directement qui vous
dira effectivement votre cas nécessite
les urgences il vient de vous prendre en
charge tout de suite ou qui veut de
grave votre cas nécessite plutôt d'aller
à la maison médicale de garde qui est à
3 rue de là on les prévient vous y allez
c'est un accès régulier
d'urgences mais que le nombre de
médecins lui ne diminue pas dans une
même ville par exemple vous allez de
dire il y a des services qui qui ferment
temporairement ou pas mais il s'agit de
regroupement non je crois qu'il faut pas
me faire dire ce que je n'ai pas dit je
n'ai pas dit qu'il y avait des services
qui ferment et j'ai dit que comme pour
les urgences comme pour d'autres
activités il y a des réorganisations à
l'échelle des territoires et qu'il faut
laisser les gens les professionnels de
ce territoire se réorganisaient que dans
le cas de ces réorganisation il pouvait
y avoir un service qui ferme au profit
d'un autre qui est à proximité immédiate
alors ce qui est quand même des zones
d'inquiétude zone géographique
d'inquiétude et puis aussi on a un
moment par exemple on est en début de
canicule est-ce qu'il y a pas des
risques d'engorgement par exemple lié et
bien à la canicule on nous a dit 62000
personnes qui sont mortes en Europe
l'année dernière à cause de la chaleur
mais vous savez la canicule c'est
d'abord un problème de société avant
d'être un problème médical la canicule
c'est passer les bons conseils à tout le
monde de s'hydrater de pas sortir aux
grandes chaleurs c'est un lien social
qui doit être créé avec les personnages
pour aller voir si elle manque de rien
parce qu'ils habitent à côté de chez
vous c'est déjà ça la canicule
intervient sur la canicule c'est que
c'est trop tard c'est à dire que toutes
les mesures de prévention n'ont pas été
correctement suivies je crois que c'est
ça le message qu'il faut passer sur la
canicule
vous parlez de services d'urgence qui ne
ferment pas y aller députés tous les
députés de la Mayenne qui vous ont écrit
personnellement pour vous dire que les
services d'urgence vitale j'en suis
vital des trois hôpitaux de la Mayenne
seront fermés cet été non ils sont en
accès régulier je je crois que mais
c'est vraiment important c'est à dire
qu'il y a ce message en permanence est
réduite non mais ça veut dire que le
service d'urgence se concentre ce
pourquoi il est fait sa savoir prendre
en charge des urgences si vous avez une
otite vous n'avez pas les bobos pour les
petits bobos j'aime pas faire une rage
dedans c'est pas les urgences qui vont
régler votre problème
par exemple concrètement si on se
présente là-bas on attend on a quelque
chose qui vient nous accueillir
traditionnel souvent paramédical qui
vient évaluer votre situation on appelle
ça des infirmières d'accueil et
d'orientation ça fait des années que ça
existe et qui va dire en contact
peut-être avec le médecin régulateur du
SAMU ou son médecin qui est sur place
lire écouter votre cas relève plutôt de
la médecine générale ils sont installés
à 2 rue de l'ail une maison médicale de
garde parce que il y a une réponse qui
s'est organisée avec les médecins
libéraux et vous allez mieux être pris
en charge là mais peut-être que en fait
vous tenez pas de compte de la douleur
en fait parce qu'il y a des personnes
qui peuvent ne pas être en urgence
vitale mais avoir une véritable
souffrance en fait avec une véritable
si c'est une otite vous allez dire que
c'est pas très grave mais ça peut faire
ça serait mal aussi vous pouvez le
penser mais vous pouvez pas le dire
comme ça je suis médecin médecin
urgentiste la douleur fait partie des
urgences et elle est d'ailleurs évaluée
à l'entrée tous les services d'urgence
donc non on peut pas dire des choses
comme ça les gens qui sont réorientés
qui sont pas horribles en termes de
douleur
des services de ville des médecins qui
ne sont pas des médecins durs
urgentistes et qui donc prendront en
espère s'ils sont disponibles l'enfant
qui est amené c'est pour ça qu'il faut
passer par la régulation médicale parce
que le médecin régulateur c'est comme ça
qu'on les appelle qui peut être un
urgentiste ou un généraliste en fonction
de l'orientation de l'appel initiale ce
médecin sait quels sont les
disponibilités autour il va savoir que
le cabinet dans la rue à côté le médecin
est parti en vacances mais que trois
rues plus loin le médecin est là et il a
dit qu'il était d'accord pour prendre en
charge ce qu'on appelle les mon
programme et c'est très important de
passer par cette tour de contrôle
qu'elle a régulation médicale et de bien
dire aux françaises et aux Français que
tout ce qui concerne les urgences les
urgences vitales les urgences graves
elles sont assurées dans notre pays soit
dans les services d'urgence soit dans
les équipes de réanimation du Samu qui
interviennent à domicile alors il y a
aussi le sas le service d'accès aux
soins donc soit on est dirigé vers les
urgences soit vers les médecins libéraux
autour de soi est-ce que faites le SAS
ne couvre que la moitié de la de la
population c'est ce que je lisais
aujourd'hui donc l'autre moitié elle
fait quoi en fait
elle a le 15 elle a toujours cette
possibilité
vous avez un lien aux urgences vous
savez il y a une grande partie des
appels qui sont réglés par un conseil
médical et puis c'est pas parce qu'il
n'y a pas le sas qu'il n'y a pas des
médecins qui sont disponibles dans
chaque secteur pour prendre en charge
des patients en médecine générale est-ce
que la loi risque qui a été votée qui
baisse la rémunération qui plafonnent la
rémunération des médecins intérimaires
n'aggravent pas un peu la situation
aujourd'hui on a vu des médecins qui
refusaient des intérimaires qui
refusaient finalement de continuer à
travailler dans ces conditions
complètement délirant de l'intérim ça
aboutissait à quoi ça aboutissait à des
à des rémunérations indécentes je le dis
parce que quand on a une rémunération de
5000 € pour 24 heures c'est un décembre
par rapport à l'infirmière à qui on
travaille par rapport au médecin
hospitalier avec qui on travaille et ça
aboutissait à une fuite des médecins de
l'hôpital c'était en train d'aggraver
notre situation de de désincarner
complètement notre système hospitalier
l'offre et la probablement un certain
nombre de médecins qui ont décidé de
faire autre chose bah très bien si si il
ne faisait médecine que par l'appât du
gain peut-être qu'il vaut mieux qu'il
fasse autre chose vous dites que le
public est le privé doit collaborer je
vous lisais encore ce matin dans Le
Figaro mais il y a la loi de 2003 qui
prévoit la suppression de l'obligation
pour les médecins libéraux de faire des
gardes et des astreintes est-ce que vous
se retournez pas finalement cette loi en
obligeant les médecins libéraux dans le
sas à prendre en charge des patients on
ne parle pas de la même chose parler de
la loi de 2003 qui concerne les médecins
généralistes navigation de garde des
médecins généralistes il faut savoir que
la suppression de cette obligation de
garde qui était inscrite dans le Code de
déontologie on a quand même aujourd'hui
96 à 98% du territoire français qui est
couvert par des médecins généralistes de
garde donc cela fonctionne
mon inquiétude elle est sur les deux à
quatre pour cent qui ne sont pas
couverts et où nous avons là une réponse
qui est une réponse publique par
l'hôpital public pour assumer pour
assumer cela donc ça ça fonctionne moi
ce que je dis dans tout le monde
participe c'est les hôpitaux et les
cliniques vous avez un hôpital la charge
cette pénibilité de la permanence des
soins c'est à dire des gardes de nuit et
des gardes de week-end et les prises en
compte essentiellement par l'hôpital
public quand vous avez des mêmes
spécialistes qui sont dans la clinique à
quelques rue de là ce que je dis c'est
arrangez-vous ensemble pour partager
cette pénibilité
notre système fonctionne sur ces deux
gens le public est privé et il
fonctionne bien comme ça simplement il
faut pas qu'il y ait un déséquilibre de
l'un par rapport à l'autre on va parler
des déserts médicaux quels sont
aujourd'hui pour vous les zones les plus
problématiques
nous avons un déficit de médecin lié à
des décennies de politique aveugles il
faut le dire un déficit de médecin
partout sur le territoire international
mais globalement c'est partout demander
à nos concitoyens ils ont bien dans le
sud que dans le Nord non ils ont pas
tout du mal pour trouver une
consultation je pense que c'est un
problème qui est qui est tout à fait
général ce qu'il faut surtout bien
comprendre c'est que je n'ai pas de
baguette magique c'est bien dommage
sinon je créerai dix mille médecins
généralistes demain et il s'installerait
partout et on aurait pu de problème y
compris dans les hôpitaux où on manque
de médecins d'ailleurs c'est pas que que
dans la médecine générale donc quelle
est la solution la solution en tout cas
la seule qui est efficace rapidement
c'est de redonner du temps médical
pourquoi parce que on a une clientèle
par médecin et quand on regarde ce que
vous avez commencé
au niveau du G7 on est tous face à la
même situation c'est international c'est
mondial cette crise au niveau du nombre
de professionnels de santé venir quid de
la coercition il y a eu de nombreux
parlementaires qui sont aujourd'hui
favorables Guillaume Garraud qui a mené
un groupe transpartisan sur une
proposition de loi qui a été débattue
récemment au Sénat il a Hervé Moret et
ça n'a pas été voté quid de la
coercition on sent de plus en plus
d'élus qui sont favorables aujourd'hui
c'est pas le problème c'est pas un tabou
c'est pas un tabou pour moi simplement
ça ne marche pas et ça va aggraver la
situation c'est ce que j'ai expliqué au
député la citation ça ne marche pas non
plus mais si l'incitation ça marche on
peut pas on peut pas laisser dire des
choses comme ça
existe en France d'ailleurs
vous croyez qu'un médecin qui veut
s'installer dans l'hôpital public qui
choisit de s'installer il va s'installer
où il y a de la place pour autant
croyez-vous que dans ces zones
désertiques il y a tous les médecins à
l'hôpital non ça fonctionne alors non ça
fonctionne pas parce que dans ces zones
là aussi on manque de praticien à
l'hôpital de toute façon on n'a pas
formé à cette médecine donc la solution
qui sont pires que d'autres et où
temporairement au moins on pourrait
avoir une certaine forme de coercition
pour dégrader les autres pour un autre
et sur quel critères la concentration de
médecins l'âge de la population les
pathologies qu'on rencontre qui sont pas
les mêmes dans l'Est de la France que
dans le Sud-Ouest il y a plein de
critères qui peuvent exister
effectivement l'âge moyen de la
population dans le département de la
Creuse il est très très élevé il y a
c'est un département désert avec très
peu d'accès aux soins on en parlera
plusieurs niveaux de réflexion
c'est-à-dire quels critères on utilise
on peut effectivement trouver plein de
critères sur l'état de santé de la
population et dire peut-être que là ce
serait mieux d'ailleurs ok maintenant
qu'est-ce qui va se passer si on met en
place cette cette coercition parce que
c'est une coercition il faut être clair
en disant vous n'avez pas le droit de
vous installer là mais vous avez le
droit de vous installer à tel endroit
moi j'ai discuté avec les médecins je
veux dire on peut discuter avec les
Françaises et les Français c'est
important sur leur ressenti les Français
les médecins les médecins ne veulent pas
les Français
moi ce que me disent les professionnels
et je sais que c'est ce qui va se passer
c'est pour ça parce que aussi ça s'est
passé dans d'autres pays ils me disent
bah très bien on va plus faire médecine
générale
je suis intimement persuadé aussi parce
que ça a été essayé ailleurs et que ça a
été un échec je suis intimement persuadé
que ça ne fonctionne pas et qu'on va
aggraver la situation en ayant moins de
médecins qui font de la médecine
générale il y a un des médecins qui vont
choisir le salariat ils iront dans des
maisons de santé dans des grandes villes
et on pourra rien leur dire en
choisissant des médecins qui vont se
décongenturer être en secteur 2 en
créant une médecine à deux vitesses ça
ne fonctionne pas alors vous formez de
nouveaux médecins en supprimant le
numerus clausus seulement les
universités elles ne sont pas
extensibles et il paraît que finalement
il y a pas assez de formations possibles
pour les jeunes qui veulent s'engager en
médecine est-ce que c'est est-ce que
c'est la vérité aujourd'hui de cette
situation alors avec la suppression du
numérique nous avons augmenté de 15%
quand même le nombre d'étudiants en
deuxième année donc c'est pas rien voilà
maintenant vous savez le problème il est
le même pour enseigner la médecine il
faut des médecins il faut des médecins
enseignants on a formé moins de médecins
pendant des décennies on a moins
d'enseignants on va pas on va pas
accepter de former plus mal la médecine
française est une médecine de qualité
qui est reconnue partout moi je veux que
les médecins qui les jeunes qui
s'engagent dans médecine ils soient bien
formés ils soient très bien formés donc
l'objectif est global il faut former
encore plus d'enseignants et c'est ce
que je fais avec les enseignants en
médecine générale en particulier c'est
mettre de stage universitaire on a
largement
énergie des possibilités de formation
pour avoir plus d'anciens
non c'est à peu près le même rythme si
vous voulez c'est pour former un
enseignant ou par exemple un professeur
d'université et bien il faut déjà qu'il
ait fait son cursus et puis c'est en
gros 5 ans oui sacrifie entre guillemets
sa vie pour être professeur des
universités pour former un enseignant un
maître de stage universitaire c'est
beaucoup moins c'est quelques semaines
et on va dans ce sens alors il y a
environ 720 000 patients souffrant
d'alld d'affection de longue durée et
qui n'ont pas de médecin traitant est-ce
que vous avez trouvé une solution pour
tous vous qui avez lancé un plan
d'action déjà il y a quelques mois il y
a un peu plus de deux mois oui nous
avons trouvé des solutions la première
des choses était d'informer tous ces
patients ce qui a été fait et 720 000
ils ont été 70000 parce que vous savez
on leur demande s'ils veulent qu'on
s'occupe de leur cas c'est un petit peu
normal il y en a qui n'ont pas de
médecins traitant mais qui ont un
médecin spécialiste très tentant je
pense au parti au lieu de diabétique qui
peuvent avoir un endocrinologue très
tangible
par courrier par courrier par mail par
tous les moyens possibles ils ont tous
été contactés j'ai confié ça à la Caisse
nationale d'assurance maladie à la
sécurité sociale et maintenant nous
sommes dans la phase de solutions
proposons un médecin traitant nous
travaillons pour cela avec les médecins
généralistes avec en particulier les
CPTs ces fameux groupements de
professionnels de santé à l'échelle d'un
territoire et aujourd'hui je peux vous
dire que un peu plus de 53000 de ses
patients on leur a trouvé un médecin
généraliste
720000 ont trouvé la solution ils ont un
référent
trouver un médecin traitant grâce au
travail qui est fait en deux mois vous
pourrez atteindre l'objectif de 720000
je fais tout pour et c'est un objectif
et quand on regarde les courbes ça
s'accélère c'est encourageant si on l'a
fait pour 53000 on va pouvoir le faire
pour 53000 donc continuons continuons
dans cet axe-là
comme satisfaction d'ailleurs et vous
faites maintenant d'ailleurs est-ce que
vous êtes toujours réservé sur l'aide
active à mourir sachant que la
convention citoyenne pour la fin de vie
c'est massivement prononcé pour cela et
que le Président de la République a
promis un texte
je me suis exprimé sur sur ma vision ma
vision des choses voilà c'est des
situations qui ne le savent pas vous
avez des situations que j'ai j'ai
connues j'ai beaucoup nombreuses dans
mon exercice professionnel ce que je dis
c'est que pour moi le principe de fin de
vie n'existe pas en tant que tel c'est à
chaque fois la fin d'une vie et la fin
d'une vie avec toute son histoire avec
toutes ces souffrances ou pas toutes ces
joies et que c'est une c'est une analyse
qui est vous allez dire à chaque fois
différente il faut vouloir généraliser
le concept moi me perturbe vous êtes
réservé sur un texte si c'est la
promesse du gouvernement absolument pas
c'est c'est une promesse du gouvernement
vous savez c'est avant d'être un
problème médical là je vous ai donné mon
mon avis personnel donc euh sur un texte
j'ai dit que c'est d'abord un problème
de société et c'est ça que je veux
mettre en avant mais la société
peut-être pas le le schéma est en route
sur les sondages non mais le scénario
est en cours le président de la
République l'a annoncé il y avait cette
convention citoyenne maintenant nous
sommes dans une phase parlementaire qui
va se dérouler jusqu'à la rentrée on
verra ce qui va sortir de cette phase
parlementaire peut-être faudrait-il
préciser des choses ou pas moi je ne
préjuge pas du résultat je dis
simplement que il faut prendre un petit
peu de hauteur c'est pas un problème
médical c'est un problème de société
c'est la façon dont notre société voit
la mort d'une façon très claire c'est un
problème qui pour moi je n'insiste n'est
pas médical c'est à dire que même si la
décision je ne pense pas que le geste
sieste il doit y avoir doit être médical
vous êtes contre le tanazie
pour moi ce n'est pas à titre à titre
personnel mais ce titre personnel il est
partagé par de très nombreux soignants
et je veux qu'on écoute et qu'on entend
des soignants c'est de dire ce n'est pas
du rôle du médecin pour moi de faire ce
type de geste voilà
et être contre le fait que ce soit un
médecin qui fasse le geste il y a une
différence si vous regardez sans parler
d'euthanasie si vous vous regardez le
suicide assisté en Suisse non mais en
Suisse c'est fait par une association
qui s'occupe de cela et c'est pas
forcément un acte médical
assister plutôt que le tanazi mais je
n'ai pas de comprendre non je crois que
je crois que il faut laisser qu'ils
fassent mais plutôt des équipes dédiées
avec la convention citoyenne un débat
apaisé j'ai pu discuter avec des membres
cette convention c'était très
intéressant ils m'ont dit nous on a
changé d'avis plusieurs fois pendant les
débats ça interpelle c'est à dire que
c'est il y a une certaine dynamique dans
la réflexion je pense qu'il faut laisser
cette cette maïeutique se fait
maintenant nous sommes dans cette phase
parlementaire peut-être il y aura-t-il
des compléments ou pas et puis on va
voir ce qui arrive et comment le discute
à ce moment merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre dans un instant un texte mais
ça dépend quel texte ça dépend si vous
êtes au gouvernement on va en parler
dans un instant avec Jim Jared du Figaro
merci beaucoup Brigitte et Tom d'avoir
été avec nous dans auditions publiques
on va on va écouter maintenant rejoindre
où et Vincent roux qui est en direct du
Figaro live bonsoir Vincent
votre question au ministre bonsoir
Elisabeth bonsoir François
alors on va faire une hypothèse c'est
que vous restez au gouvernement François
Braun et vous allez aborder le prochain
budget Bruno Le Maire annonce jusqu'à 15
milliards d'euros d'économies et la
santé est concerné un nom c'est le
ministre de l'Économie alors qu'est-ce
qui sera visé dans ces économies
budgétaires sur sur la santé on parle
des de médicaments alors quel médicament
sera des remboursé
écouter le sujet n'est absolument pas là
pour l'instant vous le savez nous
discutons du du PLFSS
2024 qui est en cours de discussion en
cours d'arbitrage d'ailleurs sur un
certain nombre sur un certain nombre de
sujets donc il faut laisser là aussi la
discussion se faire moi j'ai que la
santé participe à l'effort national
d'économie c'est tout à fait normal
c'est tout à fait naturel maintenant moi
j'ai un objectif c'est à dire que si
économie il y a dans la santé ces
économies ne doivent pas être des
économies
budgétaires dans le sens strictement
budgétaire mais doivent être des
économies qui ont une valeur en termes
de santé publique je donne un exemple
pour être très clair la France on le
sait est prescripteur d'antibiotiques
beaucoup plus que les autres pays
européens
cette prescription cette surprescription
probable d'antibiotiques elle génère de
l'antibiorésistance qui est une plaie
pour les années à venir lutter contre
cet antibiorésistance en ayant une
meilleure prescription des antibiotiques
je pense par exemple à l'utilisation de
ces tests ces trodes dans l'angine avant
de prescrire un antibiotique ça ça me
semblait être des mesures d'économique
qui sont pertinentes
très bien merci beaucoup Vincent vous
retrouve évidemment la fin de l'émission
bonjour j'aime bien avec nous du service
politique du Figaro et c'est vous qui
abordez les questions plus politiques
avec le ministre de la Santé François
Braun alors c'est l'heure encore des
grandes manœuvres au gouvernement et les
rumeurs de remaniement qui repartent de
plus belle après la séquence des émeutes
et avant le 14 juillet dans le Parisien
ce week-end Elizabeth borne a rappelé
avant la confiance du président elle a
aussi vanté son bilan est-ce que vous
dites ce soir que c'est la bonne
personne pour poursuivre l'action du
gouvernement dans ce dans ce quinquennat
écoutez moi je travaille très bien avec
la première ministre avec qui j'ai des
échanges réguliers et je n'ai pas de
de doute quant à sa capacité de elle
doit rester
le plus longtemps possible écoutez c'est
comme vous le savez c'est pas moi qui
décide mais en tout cas je peux dire que
j'ai un travail qui est constructif et
qui est fluide avec la première ministre
il y a un ministre en tout cas qui ne
cache pas ses ambitions il s'agit de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin qui fait
figure parfois dans la presse de premier
ministreble est-ce que vous diriez après
la séquence des émeutes qu'il a géré un
peu entre fermeté et compassion et bien
que cette séquence la renforcée
politiquement
je pense que cette séquence des émeutes
a été gérée
de façon graduée de façon équilibrée qui
nous a évité d'entrer dans l'état
d'urgence
que ça a été géré de façon
correcte comme je vous le disais à
l'instant par le ministère de
l'intérieur par le ministère de la
justice par le gouvernement et
l'ensemble des ministres qui ont été
directement en contact avec avec ses
émeutes je me suis moi-même déplacé à
l'hôpital de La Fontaine à Saint-Denis
le lendemain de ce mouvement un petit
peu de violence heureusement verbale qui
a eu lieu pour être sûr qu'il n'y avait
pas de débordement de ce côté là donc
oui je pense que l'affaire a été gérée
par le gouvernement comme il se doit on
nous pose souvent les ministres
issus du sérail politique à ceux qui
viennent de la société civile comme
comme c'est votre cas est-ce que vous
trouvez que cette distinction est
pertinente
non non
enfin je pense à moi qu'on me prouve que
être de la société civile et connaître
les dossiers que l'on traite est une
mauvaise chose pour être ministre mais
je ne crois pas non mais par exemple le
fait d'avoir été élu précédemment le
fait d'avoir finalement le sens du
contact politique d'avoir peut-être une
circonscription
j'ai été élu plusieurs années de suite
par les urgentistes pour présider leurs
principales syndicats est-ce que ça
suffit
à la tête d'un service d'urgence ou être
ministre de la Santé
c'est pas pareil
cette question est intéressante et je me
la suis je me suis souvent posée je vais
essayer de vous expliquer alors
rapidement si j'ai bien compris mais
c'est difficile d'être trop rapide
là-dessus la façon dont je vois les
choses je prends un exemple j'ai
beaucoup travaillé avant d'être ministre
sur les questions de gestion de crise
avec toutes les crises que l'on a
connues et en particulier comment on
doit analyser une situation prenez une
boîte en carton mettez un objet dedans
fermez la boîte faites un trou au dessus
et un trou sur le côté jusque là tout va
bien tout va bien vous regardez par le
côté
et la personne qui regarde par le côté
vous lui demandez ce qu'elle voit elle
dit je vois un triangle
à la personne qui regarde par au-dessus
vous lui demandez ce qu'elle voit elle
dit je vois un cercle
une fine et vous avez compris à
l'intérieur c'est un cône pour savoir
que c'est un cône il faut avoir ces deux
visions qui sont un peu octogonales et
c'est un peu le sentiment que j'ai
j'avais une vision du système de santé
assez large en tant qu'urgentiste mais
qui est une division par le trou du côté
et en étant ministre je vois maintenant
par le dessus et je pense avoir une
meilleure vision de ce qu'il y a à
l'intérieur de cette bulle cela peut
répondre à votre question sur les
ministres issus de la société civile
tout à l'heure avait honnêteté avoir un
mea culpa sur le fait de n'avoir pas su
convaincre vos anciens collègues sur la
convention médicale
est-ce que précisément là un peu plus
d'expérience politique ne vous a pas
manqué
c'est toujours facile de réécrire
l'histoire après peut-être peut-être pas
faire la différence et de voir la
différence entre la société civile
de la négociation politique aussi non je
pense qu'on était on était en plus dans
des circonstances je me cherche pas
spécialement d'excuse même si j'étais
pas directement à la manœuvre comme vous
le savez puisque c'est la sécurité
sociale qui gère les choses mais sur une
lettre que je leur ai que je leur ai
remise
je pense qu'on était dans une dans un
contexte qui était aussi particulier on
était dans des discussions sur la
pépliste si vous vous souvenez où il y
avait des volontés de contraindre
également donc il y a eu une surenchère
un petit peu qui est sorti donc
je pense que le contexte n'était pas bon
mais je suis quelqu'un qui est
viscéralement attaché au fait de
convaincre donc c'est pour ça que ça m'a
laissé certaines amertume vous cherchez
à convaincre mais vous avez du mal à
être connu des Français selon un sondage
odoxa publié par Le Figaro 56% des
Français
n'ont jamais entendu parler de vous euh
pas votre chaîne alors voilà peut-être
alors qu'est-ce que mais qu'est-ce que
vous avez envie de leur dire ce soir
pour leur convaincre les convaincre
pardon que vous êtes la bonne personne
au bon endroit écoutez moi je me
déplace je me déplace beaucoup sur le
terrain je vais au contact des gens
quand je les vois il me connaissent je
pense que je j'explique et j'exprime la
politique que je déploie sur beaucoup de
médias alors peut-être est insuffisant
je ne sais pas mais en tout cas vous
savez moi je
la transformation de cette refondation
de notre système de santé et les faite
d'un travail
minutieux mais d'un travail un peu de
tâches rond si vous voulez il y a pas
d'effets wahou je peux annoncer quelque
chose comme ça je sais pas je veux dire
vous n'aurez plus de problème de santé
on en parlait tout à l'heure obligation
d'installation des médecins si je dis ça
je vais être connu tout de suite partout
or je ne vous le disais je persuadé que
ça va être contre-productif je ne vais
pas le faire moi je suis plutôt à faire
un travail progressif qui cherche à
arrêter cette spirale infernale et je
pense qu'elle est arrêtée maintenant et
puis maintenant de remettre la machine
dans le bon sens pour qu'on sorte de
leur niere et vous voulez poursuivre ce
cette action au sein du gouvernement
pour continuer votre travail de de
remise en place de de ce système en
crise le plus longtemps possible parce
que ce n'est pas abouti je vous le dis
je pense que là cette spirale est en
tout cas fortement ralentie voire
arrêtée il faut la remettre dans l'autre
sens maintenant pour repartir sur de
bonnes bases j'aimerais faire ce travail
et je vais le faire d'ailleurs et puis
une fois que le train sera sur des rails
et sera bien lancé vers l'objectif donné
par le Président de la République on
verra Emmanuel Macron pardon vous avez
dit à Emmanuel Macron que vous
souhaitiez rester à votre ministère en
tout cas il m'a pas demandé si je
souhaitais rester ou partir mais il sait
que je suis des messages c'est le moment
oui mais je ne suis pas je ne suis pas
comme ça enfin je pense que il sait
je me connais il sait ma passion pour
les choses comme j'entreprends mais je
pense qu'il me connaît oui est-ce que
c'est pas un peu le supplice chinois
quand même pour les ministres en ce
moment parce que certains d'entre vous
sont donnés par temps par des
conseillers mystériels ou par là la
presse est-ce que vous vous dites
peut-être il aurait fallu un remaniement
plutôt pour que les choses soient Clares
ou alors chaque jour est bon à prendre
et puis vous continuez votre action je
crois que moi je continue mon action
comme je vous l'ai dit je mets dans une
forme d'incertitude non j'ai pas
d'incertitude moi je continue mais je
suis certain de rien personne n'est
certain de rien mais en tout cas ça ne
ça ne me pose pas de problème quand je
me rase le matin voilà et je fais mon
travail tous les jours dans l'axe qui
m'a été donné l'objectif qui m'a été
donné par le Président de la République
et la première ministre et je continue à
déployer les mesures qui sont utiles
pour atteindre cet objet ce que vous
parfois vous vous envisagez vous vous
envisagez votre avenir en dehors du
gouvernement est-ce que vous avez déjà
une idée de ce que vous feriez si jamais
vous deviez quitter le gouvernement
je suis praticien hospitalier et je suis
toujours praticien hospitalier peut-être
une question sur Emmanuel Macron
dernière question qui avait promis de
revenir dans les français pour faire le
bilan des 100 jours mais on a
l'impression que l'Elysée semble un peu
hésité sur le opportunité d'une prise de
parole est-ce que selon vous le chef de
l'étoile de prendre la parole cette
semaine le 14 juillet peut-être et je ne
me lancerai jamais dans les suppositions
de ce que doit faire ou ne pas faire le
chef de l'État c'est là le concerne je
pense que s'il veut s'exprimer auprès
des Français pour donner un petit peu le
point comme l'a fait la première
ministre ce week-end d'ailleurs
du Cap politique de ce voilà je pense
que le président s'exprimera s'il juge
que c'est nécessaire qu'il s'exprime en
tout cas qui s'exprime pas je continue à
faire mon travail merci infiniment Jim
jarrasset d'avoir été avec nous mais je
reste quand même sur la question
d'Emmanuel Macron à propos des émeutes
il avait envisagé de sanctionner
financièrement les parents des très
jeunes
émeutiers alors ensuite il a un petit
peu modéré son propos en parlant d'un
traitement au cas par cas mais quand
même cette idée elle est maintenant de
poser dans le débat pluie j'aimerais
savoir vous
d'enfants presque
personnellement comment vous vous situez
est-ce que effectivement il a nécessité
après ce qui s'est passé à
responsabiliser les parents
je pense
que la situation est beaucoup plus
complexe qu'on voudrait le mettre le
maître trop souvent en avant nous avons
eu ces phases ces phases des meute
la priorité c'est la réparation
la réparation du service public qui ont
été qui ont été agressés des écoles des
mairies c'est urgent pour que l'État
puisse continuer à continuer à
fonctionner et je pense qu'il ne faut
pas se précipiter dans
dans des diagnostics qui seraient
certainement erronées si on les faisait
trop vite et qui dit si vous permettez
cette comparaison peut-être de santé qui
dit diagnostic qui dit erronée dit
probablement pas le bon traitement et je
crois que c'est ce qu'a voulu dire le
président de la République c'est à dire
qu'il faut d'abord bien évaluer la
situation pourquoi re sommes-nous
arrivés là pourquoi des quartiers qui
n'avaient pas de problème se sont
enflammés pourquoi d'autres
identifier comme des quartiers à
problèmes ne se sont pas enflammés
pourquoi
ces émeutiers sont-ils si jeunes on a
encore beaucoup de
vous dites ne nous précipitons pas mais
pardon on a l'impression pour que
certains estiment qu'être parents
maintenant dire que les parents ont une
responsabilité c'est presque un gros mot
votre réaction est-ce que vous dites
continuez à la démarche j'allais
continuer mon explication je pense qu'il
est important de faire ce diagnostic et
de prendre un tout petit peu de temps
pas de prendre des mois mais de prendre
un peu de temps pour faire ce diagnostic
et je pense que dans les solutions les
solutions là aussi sont multinodal ou
multifocales c'est-à-dire que tout ne va
pas poser sur l'école tout ne va pas
reposer sur l'état il y a une part des
réponses et des solutions qui sont à la
main des parents à la main des familles
à cette parentalité qui peut peut-être
parfois être défaillante certaines
familles en tout cas on peut les
rappeler à leur responsabilités vous
dites il ne faut pas exclure ça dans ce
que tout le monde sa responsabilité dans
dans ses émeutes et qu'il faut répartir
les responsabilités à chacun pour
appeler cela bonjour à vous Damien
modèle merci beaucoup d'avoir vous aussi
accepté de débattre et d'interpeller le
ministre de la Santé vous êtes député et
les filles vous avez choisi deux thèmes
tout à l'heure on vous parlerait de
recal relocalisation des médicaments
en France c'est très important mais
d'abord bon le Ségur 1 faut-il un Ségur
2 c'est ça votre préoccupation de toute
évidence mais j'aimerais commencer juste
par une citation la saturation des
urgences entraîne une vraie augmentation
des complications et de la mortalité et
pas aux urgences uniquement vous savez
de quelle est cette citation peut-être
de moi parce qu'il y a déjà une étude
dans ce sens et sinon elle est reprise
parce qu'une étude française
multi-centrique et sortie il y a un mois
qui montre cette morbie mentalité
c'était d'ailleurs la suite des tunes
internationales américaines et
canadienne qui ont montré la même chose
en effet la vôtre à l'époque vous aviez
mis en place un nobet challenge pour
mesurer un obéchallenge donc en fait
c'était
président du syndicat SAMU urgence de
France pour savoir où est-ce qu'on
manquait de lit ou est-ce que ou là où
il y a des gens qui sont pas tout à fait
ça la question aujourd'hui c'est que à
l'époque vous étiez donc syndicaliste et
vous mettiez ça en avant aujourd'hui
vous êtes ministre il y a des centaines
des dizaines des centaines de services
ou justement on a d'une saturation des
urgences des fois les urgences sont
fermés tout à l'heure je vous entend
veut dire que les urgences n'étaient pas
fermées honnêtement ce n'est pas vrai ce
matin encore j'avais des urgentistes qui
m'expliquaient que cet été ils allaient
fermer un service
en Dordogne il y a les urgences qui sont
fermées la nuit par exemple on pourrait
s'y tomber aussi à Rouen où il y a des
difficultés sur terre service on
pourrait citer je crois que c'est
l'hôpital attendez mais si vous voulez
que je vous désirez
un sacré paquet un sacré paquet
d'exemple de service qui sont fermés
attendez je vous retrouve la différence
et j'ai expliqué tout à l'heure entre
fermeture et accès réguler c'est pas du
tout la même chose alors attendez alors
sur les sur les exemples les urgences de
l'hôpital de Saint-Flour ferment
plusieurs nuits les urgences de
Fontenay-le-Comte ferme plusieurs nuits
les urgences du centre hospitalier de
centre Bretagne ferme plusieurs nuits
les urgences de Brioude ferment plus
ennuis la maternité de Péronne ça c'est
la maternité qui ferme ses portes ce
mois les urgences de Sarlat qui ont
fermé plusieurs jours et plusieurs nuits
qui étaient en acquérir
plusieurs nuits on a les urgences de
Luçon qui ferment plusieurs nuits on a
l'urgence de Lannion qui ferme plusieurs
nuits on a les urgences de Saint-Nazaire
qui vont faire plaisir dans cet été
mais déjà dans quelques exemples que
vous avez cités
je vais vous je pourrais vous la donner
aujourd'hui on a décidé on a des
services qui sont saturés mais encore ce
matin j'avais un urgentiste qui
m'expliquait que quand il a pris son
service donc il y a deux jours il avait
45 personnes qui étaient qui étaient
dans les urgences et donc c'était pas
c'était pas de laboologie c'est des gens
qui étaient dans les urgences parce
qu'il fallait les garder en observation
il y en avait 12 qui étaient là depuis
plus de 24 heures et donc certains qui
étaient là même depuis 4 jours
aujourd'hui moi ce qui ce qui m'attriste
c'est qu'en vérité vous étiez d'attente
aux urgences sans être prise en charge
c'était dans les urgences parce que il y
avait pas de leaderval il y avait pas
aussi fermées notamment dans certains
services aujourd'hui on voit ça moi je
vois vous qui était qui était
syndicaliste et je me demande comment ça
ça ne peut pas vous alerter j'ai le
sentiment de plus en plus attendu j'ai
le sentiment quand je vous entends vous
dites je suis serein pour cet été
pourtant quand on parle à tous les
médecins personne ne sera pour cet été
alors on parle pas forcément mais
simplement
juste une question c'est que aujourd'hui
on a le sentiment que on est en train de
s'habituer à tout ça on est en train de
s'habituer à un moment où les gens
peuvent attendre dans les urgences et
moi ma question c'est qu'est-ce qui vous
faudra quand on voit des médecins ils
nous disent si vous voyez monsieur le
ministre dites lui qu'est-ce qu'il
faudra qu'est-ce qu'il faudra faire pour
que vous preniez enfin l'ampleur de la
situation
il y a un moment il faut que ce soit un
dialogue donc la réponse de Monsieur
aujourd'hui comment qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire pour vous dire merci
je pourrais m'amuser à vous retourner la
question puisque vous êtes membre d'un
groupe politique et j'attends d'avoir
des propositions concrètes pour savoir
ce qu'il faut faire moi ce que je fais
ce que fait le gouvernement on fait des
choses déjà on évite la saturation des
urgences en régulant l'entrée des
urgences pour que Nay aux urgences que
les gens qui ont vraiment besoin des
urgences pour justement éviter cette
saturation pour éviter cette morbi
mortalité accélérée dont vous parliez
ensuite on fait quoi et je les fais j'ai
signé il y a un peu plus d'une semaine
on gère les lits non plus à l'échelle du
seul établissement qui a son service
d'urgence mais à l'échelle de tous les
établissements du secteur c'est pas
quelque chose d'extraordinaire c'est ce
qu'on a fait pendant le covid c'est ce
qui nous a permis partout et j'étais sur
le terrain je sais je l'ai fait c'est ce
qui nous a permis de tenir pendant le
covid et on fait pareil maintenant on
responsabilise cette prise en charge des
patients
urgent non programmés sur l'ensemble
d'un territoire et puis seulement sur un
établissement et bien ça ça permet déjà
d'améliorer les choses et c'est fait
très largement en région PACA avec une
gestion qui est un peu plus large de
l'ensemble des lits disponibles donc oui
il y a des solutions oui je mets en
application des solutions maintenant si
la solution c'est de dire il faut
rouvrir des lits bien sûr bien sûr je ne
demande que ça mais pour ça faut des
professionnels c'est pas le tout d'avoir
des lignes mais des patients
s'il y a personne pour les plans pour
recruter les professionnels aujourd'hui
il y a 70% par des infirmières donc
c'est une catégorie qui dit qu'elles ne
sont pas satisfaites par les mesures du
gouvernement et que ça ne suffit pas et
vous le savez que ça ne suffit pas et
aujourd'hui on a l'impression qu'on
pourra pas aller plus loin que le Ségur
ça ne suffit pas peut-être en tout cas
il y a eu des augmentations conséquentes
par le Ségur il y a une augmentation
encore récemment annoncée du point
d'indice donc il y a une amélioration
des conditions
de nuit pour le personnel nous formons
nous rajoutons 6000 infirmières qui sont
formés la formation d'infirmière et la
formation qui est la plus demandée dans
parcoursup c'est une formation qui est
une vraie montée dans l'échelle sociale
que 50% des gens qui vont dans cette
formation sont des gens qui font partie
des questions non absolument pas c'est
la formation qui est la plus demandée
des problèmes
abandonnent d'ailleurs vous l'avez dit
vous même dans la vraie problématique
non mais laissez-moi finir parce que ça
c'est important vous dites les gens
abandonnent oui il y en a 10% qui
abandonnent la première année ça c'est
un véritable problème et on fait quoi
pour ça je suis en train de réformer
complètement la formation et le métier
d'infirmière et ça avec la satisfaction
de tous les représentants des
infirmières il faut changer ce métier
qui n'a pas évolué depuis 2004 si on ne
fait plus l'exercice infirmier de la
même façon les infirmières ont plus de
responsabilités elles travaillent main
dans la main avec les médecins et les
autres professionnels on développe les
infirmières en pratique avancées donc
oui il y a beaucoup de choses qui se
font pour les infirmières mais vous
savez comme moi que le système de santé
il se réformes pas en claquant des
doigts ni en deux mois il faut du temps
mais le sentiment qu'on a aujourd'hui
donc ne dites pas que nous avons rien
proposé il y a d'autres groupes
notamment avec la Fondation Jean Jaurès
qui ont fait des propositions seulement
aujourd'hui moi je pense qu'il faudrait
partir par exemple d'une augmentation
des salaires drastiques non pas parce
que c'est la seule chose qui est demandé
mais c'est attirer avec
l'attractivité avec ses salaires mais
après derrière il faut aussi mettre
certaines choses en place je pense que
la question des ratios n'est pas évincée
aussi facilement d'avoir un certain
nombre il faut aussi poser cette
question là il y a la question de la
pénibilité derrière à prendre en compte
mais je pense honnêtement qu'avec les
183 euros du Ségur et on le voit bien
que ça ne suffit pas c'est que depuis le
figure de la santé il y a pas eu une
croissance énorme de personnes qui
viennent travailler à l'hôpital c'est
tout l'inverse moi mon sentiment c'est
qu'on ne va pas faire le mieux
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment des gens vous disent on va
aller vers le mieux pour l'hôpital
personne ne sera un par vous et c'est
bien ça vous le voyez bien quand vous
êtes parce que justement je me déplace
beaucoup et dans beaucoup d'endroits y
des endroits où ça ne va pas bien vous
dites les gens il y a un problème
d'attractivité à l'hôpital oui mais bien
entendu je suis tout à fait d'accord et
quand je discute avec les personnels ce
n'est pas qu'un problème de salaire
c'est un problème de conditions de
travail c'est pour ça que là je mène la
réforme pour revenir à l'échelle du
service à une échelle humaine dans
l'hôpital et non pas ses grands pôles
gigantesques où les gens ne se
retrouvent plus c'est pour ça que on
diminue tout ce qui n'est pas de
l'activité de soins que ce soit en ville
comme à l'hôpital d'ailleurs donc il y a
beaucoup de choses à faire autour de ça
c'est pour ça que je réforme
complètement ce métier d'infirmière qui
a d'autres objectifs maintenant qui ne
s'exercent plus de la même façon oui il
y a des choses à faire pour l'hôpital
vous parliez des ratios je vais revenir
sur cette notion de ratio est-ce que ça
vous êtes entre vous là c'est quoi les
ratiosité
il faut tant d'infirmière alors moi je
suis pas tout à fait d'accord sur le
principe de ratio vous avez raison je
dis qu'il faut le nombre de personnels
en lien avec la charge en soins ça veut
dire quoi c'est une de ratio vous savez
je connais bien l'hôpital j'ai travaillé
38 ans vous disiez vous pouvez avoir
deux services de médecine vous avez un
service de médecine ou le médecin une
orientation plutôt de maladies un peu
rares ou de rhumatologie par exemple
avec plutôt des patients jeunes et
plutôt des durées de séjour courtes et
vous avez le même service et médecine
avec des patients plutôt de 70 ans et
des durées longues et des patients qui
sont dépendants et bien mettre un ratio
identique pour tout ce qui s'appelle
service de médecine c'est une erreur par
contre dire que on évalue la charge en
soins et nous avons des outils
d'évaluation de la charge en soi
unique pour tous les services ça c'est
une évidence
sur les financement moi j'ai du mal à
croire aujourd'hui qu'on pourra faire
mieux sur l'hôpital public avec moins
d'argent aujourd'hui la Fédération
hospitalière de France disent qu'il leur
manque entre 1,5 et 2 milliards d'euros
ne serait-ce que pour compenser
l'inflation on a Bruno Le Maire qui nous
fait des menaces sur le fait qu'ils vont
aujourd'hui sacrifier une partie du
budget de la santé vous savez que c'est
vrai que le pffss n'est pas la hauteur
même monsieur Miss on sait même croisé
un moment donné je vous ai demandé le
budget ça ne va pas vous m'avez dit non
ça ne va pas aujourd'hui vous le voyez
bien qu'on manque de finance et c'est
impossible de faire croire aux gens
qu'on va faire mieux avec moins d'argent
mais j'ai pas dit qu'on ferait mieux
avec mien en tout cas je l'ai je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure on en a parlé que si
les économies il doit y avoir c'est des
économies qui ont un sens en terme de
santé publique et je donnais l'exemple
de la trop de prescription
d'antibiotiques donc en tout cas moi je
ferai pas de coupe sur l'hôpital aveugle
financière ça c'est d'un autre temps
maintenant nous sommes dans une logique
où on met en avant la prévention ou au
moins en avant la réponse aux besoins de
la population et c'est dans ce sens là
que je vais
sur la question des relocalisations
alors enchaînons sur la question des
relocalisations il y a eu un rapport qui
est sorti vous l'avez sans doute vu au
Sénat aujourd'hui deux questions simples
est-ce que la France doit produire une
partie de ces médicaments nous on pense
qu'il faut que la France produise une
partie de ces médicaments notamment ceux
qui ont été en pénurie ça peut être le
cas de l'amoxine et la France au sens
que l'État se prenne en charge c'est
cette dimension là et l'autre point
c'est la conditionnalité des aides moi
je suis à la commission des finances je
vois que nous donnons des crédits
d'impôts à tout va notamment il y a le
crédit d'impôt recherche dont on
pourrait parler et à des groupes qui des
fois supprime la moitié de leurs
effectifs de recherche aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il faut une
conditionnalité des aides sur la
relocalisation parce qu'on a eu la liste
on a le sentiment qui a rien de
contraignant et qu'elle pourrait partir
du jour au lendemain alors il y a il y a
un enjeu majeur et je vous rejoins sur
la lutte contre les pénuries d'une façon
très générale c'est un enjeu qui n'est
pas que français vous le savez c'est un
enjeu qui pour le coup l'international
c'était l'objet de la dernière
discussion avec mes homologues européens
il y a il y a un mois et demi c'était
entièrement sur cette pénurie de
médicament dans les réponses à la
pénurie de médicaments il y a plusieurs
plusieurs des éléments et d'ailleurs
c'est le plan pénurie que je porte avec
la définition de cette liste de
médicaments essentiels d'après le Sénat
qui est flou
j'ai été à la commission des affaires
sociales du Sénat j'aurais expliqué la
façon dont cette liste avait été faite
et ils sont tout à fait satisfaits de
rapport oui mais le rapport est sorti le
matin même et j'étais reçu l'après-midi
donc réécoutez-moi au Sénat vous aurez
l'explication qui convient le président
de la République c'est c'est engagé dans
le cadre de la de France 2030 à
relocalisé de la production de
médicaments 25 molécules qui vont être
localisées en France il y a la
relocalisation en France il y a la
relocalisation en Europe et d'ailleurs
la France soutient un projet belge et on
n'est pas allé seul à le soutenir on est
une vingtaine de pays déjà à le soutenir
sur la relocalisation entre autres de la
relocalisation en Europe d'un certain
production de médicaments
et en France bien entendu mais vous
parlez de l'amoxicilline amoxicine est
produite en Europe donc le problème de
la pénurie que nous avons eu
d'amoxicilline très bien doubler des
productions il n'est pas il est pas il
est pas lié uniquement un problème de
production il est lié aussi un problème
de mauvais anticipation de la
consommation et une explosion de la
consommation en poste covid ah ça c'est
vrai que vous avez je pense mal anticipé
pour le coup sur la question de la
condition je peux pas vous laisser dire
ça c'est pas la France qui a mal
anticipé sur les industriels qui ont
prévu leur production sur les chiffres
de l'année précédente et donc et on
était en plein covid et on avait des
nouvelles et bien justement la question
des aides sur la condition c'est le
principe de cette liste des médicaments
essentiels d'avoir une cartographie de
l'ensemble de la production d'imposer
aux industriels des contraintes il y en
a déjà vous le savez très bien sur la
liste des 3000 médicaments on a des
contraintes de stock qui vont de 1 mois
à trois mois en fonction des types de
médicaments
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
c'est des contraintes qui sont liées
simplement au fait que on paye les
médicaments pour qu'il soit sur le
marché français et sur la
conditionnalité des aides aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'une entreprise qui touche des
aides est-ce qu'elle pourra les toucher
mais ensuite tout de même supprimer les
postes de chercheurs et délocaliser
Sanofi durant le covid à tous les 200
millions d'euros une semaine après ils
ont supprimé 1000 postes est-ce que ça
ce sera encore possible ce sera la
dernière réponse
ça fait partie des choses à discuter
comme j'ai dit il y a pas de tabou et
tout doit être mis sur la table pour que
les Français n'aient plus cette pénurie
de médicaments
il y a des discussions actuelles je vais
pas je vais pas faire des conclusions
avant le groupe de travail qui est
impossible de dire si on donne de
l'argent ils doivent respecter dans ce
sujet dans ce sujet précis des relations
et du prix de médicaments avec les
industriels la première ministre a mis
en place un groupe de travail composé de
Novartis
de l'industrie c'est pas parce qu'ils
sont aussi un industrie
pour me positionner ils vont donner leur
conclusions et en fonction de leur
conclusion je me positionne sur ce qui
doit être de la part d'un groupe
d'experts composés majoritairement de
gens de l'industrie pharmaceutique de
réguler l'industrie pharmaceutiques
des 450 médicaments que on ne sait pas
d'où viennent les professionnels
qui viennent des sociétés savantes je
crois qu'il y a un moment donné il faut
arrêter de toujours pas d'affirmation
sur la régulation des aides pas de
négation non plus
donc ça ça veut dire qu'il y aura rien
enfin on connaitre
des décisions mais on crée un groupe de
travail de spécialistes on leur demande
un avis la moindre des choses c'est
d'attendre leur avis vous êtes déçu par
la réponse hein merci en tout cas
monsieur modèle d'avoir été avec nous
restait encore quelques instants Vincent
roux au figuerolive une question pour le
ministre
oui c'est une question d'actualité
François Brown alors un petit peu loin
de votre domaine d'action pour l'instant
mais c'est une une question qui va
s'inviter pendant les 48 prochaines
heures c'est le sommet de l'OTAN qui se
tient à Vilnius c'est une question qu'on
pose sur le site du Figaro est-ce que
vous êtes favorable à l'adhésion de
l'Ukraine à l'OTAN j'allais vous dire
est-ce que vous y êtes favorable avant
la fin de la guerre
effectivement ça sort un petit peu de
mon champ mon champ de compétences je
suis je suis favorable à toutes l'aide
que l'on peut apporter en Ukraine
j'y étais moi-même il y a quelques mois
elles vivent d'ailleurs qui a été
bombardée et au niveau sanitaire nous
apportons un soutien important au niveau
du l'Ukraine y compris avec des
professionnels qui sont d'ailleurs en ce
moment à vivre au centre de au centre de
rééducation je pense qu'il faut que
cette situation cesse que cette guerre
d'agression de la Russie cesse une bonne
fois pour toute et puis seront dans des
conditions
satisfaisantes pour envisager l'avenir
je pense que malheureusement les
Ukrainiens avec cette guerre ont du mal
à envisager même leur avenir en tout cas
c'est ce qui me disait sur place
voilà Vincent merci beaucoup une
question sur le covid monsieur le
ministre avant qu'on se quitte parce que
ça nous a suffisamment quand même
impacté dans notre vie quotidienne on en
parle plus du tout mais plus il a
disparu
il est toujours présent il est présent
il est 13 ans un taux extrêmement faible
un peu comme les virus les virus
hivernaux mais encore des Français qui
attrapent le covid
le covid qui est une forme heureusement
peu grave pour les gens qui qui n'ont
pas de problème de santé particulier qui
comme la grippe peut être très grave
pour les gens qui ont des problèmes de
santé et je serai amené à porter une
campagne pour les maladies de l'hiver et
apporter aussi une campagne de
vaccination grippe covid pour les
Français les plus fragiles si vous êtes
toujours donc ministre de la Santé à la
rentrée prochaine il y aura une nouvelle
campagne de vaccination un rappel du
vaccin pour ce évidemment il y aura je
porterai cette campagne ne vous
inquiétez pas et vous ne dites que vous
serez aux manettes à ce moment-là
merci infiniment d'avoir été avec nous
c'est la fin de cette émission dernière
de la saison clap de fin d'ailleurs pour
audition publique permettez-moi de
remercier en particulier tous ceux qui a
la technique nous ont accompagné tout au
long de ces émissions Jean-Sébastien
perdreau son Frédéric choquer à la
réalisation Laurent Leroy truquiste je
vous appelle GIC script Christophe
lafalise à la vision Nicolas Bro
précieux assistant plateau et au
maquillage Virginie Darmon et puis merci
évidemment à toute l'équipe de rédaction
Germain Andrieu et Léonore Picot et les
formidable journaliste que vous avez vu
encore ce soir Brigitte
Brigitte boucher Tam traduit
Jim jerras et du Figaro ifstraire qui
n'était pas là ce soir mais qui était un
pilier d'audition publique merci
monsieur le ministre d'avoir été invité
de la dernière bonne soirée bien sûr et
à bientôt sur le canal 13 LCP est public
Sénat bonne soirée
[Musique]